changing my tight alkaline metal time
you have an alkaline metal cars a new
type just got this one's a Dutch one was
given it on Saturday so here you can see
we have the alkaline metals where are
they here and the alkali metals are very
reactive so we've seen that lithium
doesn't react very much but then as you
go to sodium and then to potassium and
rubidium the violence of the reaction
gets more and more and more and cesium
is even greater I don't know whether the
people making this time were so
frightened that they didn't put it on
but in each of these cases the reaction
is removing one electron after another
one electron from the outer atom out
shell of the atom and the bigger the
atom the easier it is to remove the
electron and as you go down the periodic
table the size of the atom increases so
it's easier to remove the electron so
francium would almost certainly be even
bigger than cesium because it's a whole
row lower down and so that should react
with water with enormous violence but
unfortunately francium is very
radioactive and you can't get a nice
lamp of francium that the sort of size
that you'd like to throw in water to to
make the youtube video of the century
francium which named after france was
discovered by one of Madame Curie's
pupils in 1939 five years after Madame
Curie herself died I always thought that
it was Madame Curie that discovered it
but in fact it was discovered after her
death but its properties would probably
be similar to those of caesium if it was
not very radioactive but radioactivity
like that makes it very difficult for
chemists
to study the chemistry in enormous
detail chemical reactions are really
quite sensitive to temperature and
radioactive materials as they decay give
out energy so the compounds themselves
tend to heat up a lump of plutonium
which is very regulative is really quite
warm to touch and francium which i think
is more radioactive is probably very
warm so I think the melting point of
francium will be lower than that of
cesium because the melting points go
down the group and because it will be
generating heat almost certainly
francium would be liquid at room
temperature I've never seen it it might
well be coloured as well because cesium
is golden colored so I would not be
surprised if francium was red but I am
no idea and I'm not sure if anybody
knows